Без кота мышам раздолье
Bes kata mysham rasdolje, amigos, este viejo
proverbio ruso, que tiene sus versiones en
prácticamente todos los idiomas, más o menos
viene a decir que “Sin un gato, hay libertad
para los ratones”.
Como todo el mundo sabe, el gato Putin está
muy ocupado con Ucrania.
Así que, por si no tuviéramos bastantes
guerras en este 2022, ha resucitado de nuevo
el viejo conflicto de Nagorno-Karabaj.
Azerbaiyán lanza ataques de gran alcance
contra Armenia
Como el Kremlin no está actualmente en condiciones
de mediar entre ambos como siempre hizo, Azerbaiyán
ha vuelto a la carga con la novedad de que
esta vez ha atacado directamente territorio
armenio.
Y esto es un problema para Europa.
Porque Azerbaiyán suministra gas a la Unión
Europea pero sobre todo porque es una de las
opciones que está barajando Bruselas para
reemplazar al gas ruso.
Otra alternativa está al otro lado del mar
Caspio.
Hablamos de Turkmenistán, que cuenta con
las cuartas reservas de gas más grandes del
mundo.
El problema de ambos países es que son dictaduras
que antaño pertenecían a la Unión Soviética
y que se encuentran en lo que el Kremlin ha
considerado siempre como la esfera de influencia
rusa.
Sin embargo amigos, la guerra de Ucrania lo
está cambiando todo.
Y donde hay una crisis, hay una oportunidad.
No solo a nivel energético sino también
político.
Porque estamos ante la oportunidad de la Unión
Europea para que Asia Central entre en su
zona de influencia y no en la de otras potencias.
Y mucho ojo, porque no estamos hablando de
Rusia precisamente.
El presidente chino, Xi Jinping, busca abrir
puertas en Asia Central mientras la guerra
en Ucrania deja deteriorada a Rusia
La cuestión es que Europa está empezando
a dar pasos hacia Asia Central pero, como
podéis imaginar, negociar con este tipo de
dictaduras no da buena imagen y solo es fuente
de problemas.
Nunca será plato de buen gusto decir que
entre los mejores amigos de Bruselas están
los Aliyev o el nuevo dictador de Turkmenistán,
el hijo de Arkadag, viejo conocido de VisualPolitik.
Los que nos seguís desde hace unos años
ya sabéis unas cuantas historias de este
auténtico pirado, que hizo erigir estatuas
de oro de él mismo y de su perro favorito.
Quizás para Europa sea mejor depender de
varios demonios que de uno solo, pero visto
el panorama, eso no significa que vaya a ser
sencillo salir del infierno.
Así que la pregunta es: ¿Qué problema supone
para la Unión Europea que Azerbaiyán ataque
de nuevo a Armenia?
¿Cómo puede Bruselas meter a Asia Central
en su zona de influencia?
¿De verdad puede tener gas barato y a la
vez meterle un gol a Rusia y a China?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes… vamos a ver un poco
de historia.
TÍTULO: LA VITAMINA CHINA
Nuestra historia de hoy comienza muy lejos
de Turkmenistán.
Concretamente a 4.500 kilómetros.
Vamos a viajar a un lugar del Índico del
que ya os hemos hablado un montón en VisualPolitik.
Me estoy refiriendo a las islas de Andamán
y Nicobar, un archipiélago perteneciente
a la India que es el gran talón de Aquiles
de China.
La economía china devora recursos sin cesar.
Esto convierte a China en un gigante con pies
de barro porque no tiene recursos naturales
suficientes en su territorio y buena parte
de sus suministros de petróleo y de otras
materias primas pasan por el Estrecho de Malaca.
Así que, si en algún momento las cosas se
pusieran feas con China, sus rivales podrían
aprovechar las islas de Andamán y Nicobar
para bloquear la navegación por el Índico
y dejarles sin recursos.
Aquí es donde para China empieza a cobrar
relevancia Asia Central.
Estamos hablando de una región que hasta
hace poco no le importaba a nadie salvo a
Rusia.
Porque sí, Asia Central tiene muchos recursos
naturales pero escasa capacidad de explotarlos.
Un buen ejemplo de esto es Turkmenistán.
Al ritmo de producción actual, Rusia tiene
reservas de gas para 58 años y Qatar para
144.
Bueno, pues Turkmenistán tiene gas para los
próximos 230 años.
Esto nos indica dos cosas: que tienen mucho
gas y que no están sacándole partido a todo
lo que tienen bajo tierra.
Se necesita mucha inversión para poner en
marcha un campo de producción de gas y más
aún para instalar la infraestructura necesaria
para exportarlo.
Pero claro, allí donde hay hidrocarburos,
China siempre ha estado dispuesta a poner
los yuanes necesarios para que esto fuera
realidad.
El gasoducto China-Asia Central, que atraviesa
Uzbekistán y Kazajistán, permite a China
desde el año 2010 obtener gas de Turkmenistán.
Antes este país le vendía a Rusia la mayor
parte de su gas pero las cosas han cambiado
mucho en los últimos años.
Tanto que ya en 2021 le exportó a Beijing
31 bcm, es decir, 31.000 millones de metros
cúbicos de gas, el triple respecto a los
10 bcm que le vendió a Moscú.
Turkmenistán es el principal suministrador
de gas a China por gasoducto y el segundo
en total si tenemos en cuenta el GNL, el gas
natural licuado de Australia.
De hecho, la capacidad del gasoducto Power
of Siberia, que conecta Rusia con China, es
similar a la del gasoducto China-Asia Central.
Todo esto subraya la importancia que Turkmenistán
tiene para China.
Todos nos hemos enterado de la última reunión
de Xi Jinping con Putin en Samarcanda.
Pero es que el presidente chino se reunió
también con los líderes de los 5 países
de Asia Central.
Este interés de Beijing en la región se
traduce en que a medida que crece la influencia
china, disminuye la rusa.
Y hay 3 motivos por los que esta tendencia
irá a más: el primero es que China es un
socio comercial más atractivo que Rusia.
En segundo lugar, nadie quiere apostar por
el caballo perdedor y hombre, lo de Ucrania
no pinta bien para Putin.
Y por último, no hay que olvidar que Kazajistán
es el país referencia de la región y hace
poco hemos visto en VisualPolitik como quiere
marcar distancias frente al Kremlin.
De hecho ha vuelto a hacerlo con un artículo
firmado por el propio presidente Tokayev en
Politico, el medio estrella de los políticos
de Bruselas.
Presidente de Kazajistán: Avanzamos a toda
velocidad hacia la reforma
Que China gane influencia en Asia Central
es un problema para Europa, pero también
para Estados Unidos.
Fundamentalmente porque a medida que Beijing
se hace con los recursos naturales de estos
5 países, disminuye la importancia de un
posible bloqueo a los suministros con dirección
a China.
Y claro, desde un punto de vista geopolítico,
Occidente quiere que el statu quo siga igual
porque le interesa mantener la carta de la
disuasión en el Índico.
Pero es que además también está la posibilidad
de que Turkmenistán venda su gas natural
a Europa, lo cual le vendría genial para
reducir la dependencia de Rusia.
Ahora mismo la Comisión Europea está buscando
la fórmula para reemplazar los 150 bcm que
se compran a Rusia cada año.
El objetivo es diversificar los suministros.
Con Estados Unidos ya se ha cerrado un acuerdo
para hacerse con su gas natural licuado.
Así lo explicó la presidenta Ursula Von
der Leyen.
Estados Unidos y Europa garantizarán una
demanda y un suministro estables de al menos
50.000 millones de metros cúbicos adicionales
de GNL de Estados Unidos hasta 2030.
Y si nos fijamos en eso, esta cantidad, 50
bcm por año, ya está reemplazando un tercio
del gas ruso que está llegando a Europa hoy
día.
El problema es que el GNL es más caro que
el que llega por gasoducto.
Tener energía barata era hasta ahora nuestra
principal baza de competitividad frente a
Asia.
Así que Europa necesita gas procedente de
diferentes sitios, sí.
Pero a ser posible barato, porque digo yo
que en algún momento Europa necesita volver
a ser competitiva.
Por tanto, más allá del GNL estadounidense,
la mejor opción para los 27 pasa por las
tuberías que sean capaces de traer más gas
del Cáucaso y de Asia Central.
Vamos a ver qué se está haciendo.
Atentos.
TITULO: YO PONGO EL CAVIAR, TÚ PONES LAS
LATAS
Azerbaiyán lleva medio siglo gobernado por
la misma familia: los Aliyev.
En casa gobiernan con puño de hierro pero
con los de fuera se esfuerzan mucho por agradar.
Sobre todo si son europeos.
Su problema es que hacer tratos con dictaduras
nunca es agradable.
Así que desde Bakú pusieron en marcha algo
que los seguidores más veteranos de VisualPolitik
ya conocéis: la diplomacia del caviar.
Porque claro, con dinero y con caviar es más
fácil hacer amigos.
Bueno, y también con señoritas de muy buen
ver.
Porque Azerbaiyán no se ha cortado un pelo
a la hora de comprar a los políticos europeos.
Llegaron incluso a dar instrucciones desde
Bruselas para que los diplomáticos estuvieran
alerta.
Que si una muchacha atractiva se acercaba
y te decía algo parecido a (acento azerí)
“quiero saber cómo de largo es tu gasoducto”,
mucho ojo, que en realidad te busca por el
interés e intentan pillarte con algo turbio
para que luego tengas que defender los intereses
de Bakú.
Intereses como el Southern Gas Corridor, el
Corredor Sur del Gas.
¿De qué estamos hablando?
De esto.
También hubo muchas presiones para que este
proyecto se quedara en un cajón.
Porque Rusia llegó a financiar a partidos
políticos como el Movimiento 5 Estrellas
de Italia para evitar que este gasoducto se
construyera.
Al final la última parte del Corredor Sur
del Gas, el TAP, el gasoducto Transadriático,
empezó a operar en diciembre de 2020.
Esto ha permitido que actualmente Azerbaiyán
le esté vendiendo a Europa 10 bcm.
Hombre, comparado con los 150 bcm que llegan
de Rusia no son nada.
Pero lo importante es que se han vuelto las
tornas por completo.
Con la guerra de Ucrania, resulta que ahora
somos los europeos los que hemos pasado a
suplicar a Azerbaiyán que nos dé más gas.
Bruselas ya cerró un acuerdo con Azerbaiyán
para duplicar los envíos de gas para 2027.
Allá en Bakú estuvo Von der Leyen, que tan
pronto está con Biden como con Aliyev.
Nos comprometemos a la ampliación del Corredor
Sur de Gas.
Y ampliaremos su capacidad a 20.000 millones
de metros cúbicos en unos años.
A partir del próximo año deberíamos llegar
ya a los 12.000 millones de metros cúbicos.
Esto ayudará a compensar los cortes en el
suministro de gas ruso.
Tampoco te emociones Úrsula, que con 20 bcm
en Italia se quedan sin gas en un par de meses.
Porque esa es la auténtica realidad del Corredor
Sur del Gas: trae poco gas a Europa y, por
mucho que en 2027 vaya a llegar el doble,
seguirá siendo poco.
Ahora bien, vamos a fijarnos en el TANAP,
el gasoducto Transanatolio.
TANAP, de 1.840 kilómetros, coge el gas de
Azerbaiyán en la frontera con Georgia y cruza
toda Turquía hasta la frontera con Grecia,
donde arranca el TAP.
Este gasoducto, que mayoritariamente es propiedad
de SOCAR, la compañía estatal azerí, tiene
capacidad para 16 bcm, de los cuales 6 se
quedan en Turquía, 2 en Grecia y 8 llegan
hasta Italia.
Pues bien, lo más importante es que este
gasoducto está diseñado como un gasoducto
escalable.
Esto significa que su capacidad se puede ir
ampliando añadiendo circuitos paralelos y
más potencia con estaciones compresoras.
Esto significa que con una inversión contenida,
alrededor de 7.000 millones de dólares, pasará
a tener una capacidad de 32 bcm.
Pero esperad un momento, porque hace 10 años
los planes de SOCAR eran transportar 60 bcm,
lo cual son palabras mayores.
Y claro, la gran pregunta es: ¿por qué Azerbaiyán
no explota esto?
En primer lugar porque hacen falta muchos
millones para desarrollar los campos de producción
de gas.
Shah Deniz, el megayacimiento de Azerbaiyán,
ha significado una inversión de 27.000 millones
de dólares para que actualmente produzca
21 bcm al año.
Con este dinero se pueden construir más de
70 hospitales a todo trapo.
Y aquí es cuando Azerbaiyán le ha dicho
a Europa.
Amiga Úrsula, yo pongo el caviar, pero tú
pones las latas:
El presidente Aliyev dice que aumentar las
exportaciones de gas requiere inversiones
y garantías
Aliyev ha dicho que si Europa quiere más
gas, que vengan sus petroleras a invertir
en Azerbaiyán.
Y os preguntaréis, pero ¿Por qué Azerbaiyán
antes nos daba caviar y ahora nos da calabazas?
Bueno, pues porque Bakú desconfía de las
intenciones de Europa a largo plazo.
Y tiene 3 motivos para hacerlo: primero, no
hay absolutamente nada que impida que Europa
vuelva a comprar gas a Rusia.
Pueden pasar mil cosas: que Putin entre en
razón y se rinda, que haya una revolución,
que caiga un meteorito en el Kremlin…
yo qué sé, no parece probable, pero no es
imposible.
Luego está la transición energética, que
con las renovables o con nuevas nucleares
Europa quizás necesite menos gas.
Y también puede ser que Estados Unidos suministre
más GNL aún.
Pero es que si Azerbaiyán desconfía de Europa,
en Bruselas tampoco se quedan atrás.
Piensan que no tiene sentido dejar de depender
de Rusia para pasar a depender de Azerbaiyán.
Porque los Aliyev dirigen una dictadura muy
represiva.
Y además, cuantos más euros se empleen en
comprar gas de Azerbaiyán, más van a tener
para financiar la guerra con Armenia.
Así que toda la atención recae ahora sobre
Turkmenistán.
Lo vemos.
EL PARAÍSO DEL GAS
¿Os imagináis un país con unas reservas
de gas 5 veces más grandes que las de Azerbaiyán?
No hace falta imaginarlo, así es Turkmenistán.
También es una dictadura, una especie de
versión estúpida de Corea del Norte.
Por fortuna a su gerifalte le ha dado más
por las estatuas de oro que por las bombas
nucleares.
Este rey Midas moderno se jubiló el pasado
marzo.
Eso sí, antes le sucedió su único hijo
varón: Serdar Berdimuhamedow.
Posiblemente esto les parecerá espantoso
a muchos.
Una dictadura hereditaria, ¿es que nunca
vamos a espabilar de hacer tratos con esta
gente?
Pues bueno, al menos, Turkmenistán es una
dictadura que no pretende invadir a nadie.
Por ahí podemos estar tranquilos ya que las
fuerzas armadas turkmenas han mostrado esta
ferocidad para recibir a su nuevo dictador.
¡Es pegadizo eh!
(Ponerse serio) Pero no, no son precisamente
el terror de Asia Central.
Así que la Unión Europea debería buscar
un acuerdo similar al alcanzado por China.
El gigante asiático le dijo a Turkmenistán:
no te preocupes por nada, yo exploto el yacimiento
y te construyo el gasoducto.
Luego ya me pagas los servicios prestados
con gas.
Y vamos, se ve que los chinos añadieron algún
0 a la factura porque Turkmenistán todavía
no ha visto un yuan por su gas.
Pero ¿habéis visto cómo bailan?
Están encantados.
Y muchos estaréis pensando: pero bueno: ¿y
por qué a Europa no se le ocurrió antes
algo así?
Fundamentalmente porque sería necesario construir
el gasoducto transcaspiano.
Este proyecto ha estado bloqueado durante
décadas porque tenían que dar su visto bueno
todos los países ribereños del mar Caspio,
lo que incluye a Rusia e Irán.
Sin embargo amigos, la situación ha cambiado
desde 2018, cuando se firmó el acuerdo internacional
sobre el status legal del mar Caspio.
Ahora bastaría con un acuerdo entre Azerbaiyán
y Turkmenistán para construir el gasoducto.
Algo factible después de que ambos países
hayan resuelto su eterna disputa por un yacimiento
de gas.
Turkmenistán y Azerbaiyán desarrollarán
conjuntamente el campo Dostluk en el Caspio
En cualquier caso, pueden pasar varios años
hasta que se construya el gasoducto transcaspiano,
y eso si llega a hacerse.
Así que ya se barajan 3 alternativas para
que el gas de Turkmenistán llegue a Azerbaiyán
camino de la Unión Europea.
Una fórmula es hacerlo llegar a territorio
azerí mediante barco convertido en gas natural
comprimido.
Otra opción es la que propone la empresa
estadounidense Trans Caspian Resource: un
interconector de 48 millas para que el gas
turkmeno transite entre un yacimiento de Turkmenistán
y otro de Azerbaiyán que están en aguas
del Caspio.
Y la tercera fórmula ya está funcionando.
Y mucho ojo, porque interviene un actor de
lo más inesperado:
Turkmenistán inicia suministro de gas de
intercambio a Azerbaiyán a través de Irán
Según este acuerdo a tres bandas, Turkmenistán
suministrará anualmente 4 bcm a Irán en
su frontera noreste.
Y las regiones del noroeste de la república
islámica, que producen gas, suministrarán
cada año 4 bcm a Azerbaiyán.
Como podéis ver, que Europa consiga el gas
de Turkmenistán no va a ser sencillo.
Tampoco será la panacea.
Pero sí es la mejor manera de atraer Asia
Central a la esfera de influencia europea
y evitar dejar el terreno libre a China en
la región.
Supondría anotarse un tanto en el ámbito
de la seguridad y en el económico, al conseguir
un suministro de gas estable y barato.
Y es la oportunidad de ser el nuevo gato en
la región.
Pero ahora las preguntas son para vosotros:
¿Creéis que Europa debería apostar por
el gasoducto transcaspiano?
¿O creéis que ya está bien de lidiar con
dictaduras y que la auténtica alternativa
al gas ruso es nuclear más renovables?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.